Disney likes to call its Theme Park
complex in Florida the happiest place on
Earth but its executives are not so
happy now it all started just over a
year ago when Florida passed what
critics call the don't say gay law it
Outlaws teaching about sexual
orientation and gender identity to
Children up to the third grade the CEO
of Disney criticized the law that didn't
sit well with Governor Ron DeSantis we
view that as a provocation for more than
50 years Disney has been empowered to
act as its own local government for its
theme parks and surrounding area
approving building projects collecting
taxes building roads funding
firefighters and police officers but
DeSantis recently signed a law to strip
them of that Authority putting his
hand-picked board in charge of the
district occupied by Disney which brings
tens of millions of tourists to the
state every year a move criticized by
some economic analysts all of this
special district does like any other
special district is raise revenue and
provide services If you eliminate it it
just means that other governments cities
and Counties have to raise revenues to
pay for those services or they have to
reduce those Services after back and
forth for control Disney has now sued to
get its power back DeSantis is expected
to run for president during an overseas
trip likely meant to burnish its foreign
policy credentials DeSantis remained
defiant whereas every other Floridian
has to have this this type of oversight
all Florida businesses so it's um it's a
it's a little bit much to be complaining
about that I don't think the suit has
Merit I think it's political in a recent
poll 44 percent of Republicans said they
had a more favorable view of DeSantis
because of his fight with Disney
but the same poll shows the majority of
Americans were less likely to support a
candidate who punishes companies for
speaking out
DeSantis and his wife Casey were married
at Disney in 2009 but 14 years later the
escalating dispute could hurt him
politically if he gets the Republican
nomination this has already been a
costly fight but it's not yet clear
Which side will pay the most for it
Patty Colleen Al Jazeera Washington